vamos a resolver más de estos problemas
de sistemas de masas y recuerden que hay
una forma fácil y una forma difícil de
hacerlo la forma difícil es aplicar la
ley de newton para cada uno de estos
objetos
luego las combinamos y vamos a obtener
dos ecuaciones con dos incógnitas
tenemos que hacer un buen uso del
álgebra para no perder ningún signo por
ahí pero seamos honestos es muy probable
que nos equivoquemos la forma más fácil
de resolver esto la forma de encontrar
la magnitud de la aceleración de todos
los objetos en el sistema es es decir si
yo quiero saber la magnitud de la
aceleración en esta masa de 5 kilogramos
o en esta masa de 3 kilogramos lo que
tengo que hacer es encontrar la fuerza
neta externa que está afectando a mi
sistema y esto lo divido entre la masa
total de mi sistema
esta es una forma rápida de encontrar la
magnitud de la aceleración de los
objetos en mi sistema pero recordemos
que esto sólo funciona si los objetos en
mi sistema necesitan moverse con la
misma aceleración y en este caso así es
tengo esta masa de 5 kilogramos que está
atada a una cuerda que a su vez está en
una polea y esta cuerda también sostiene
una masa de 3 kilogramos por lo que si
esta masa de 5 kilogramos tiene una
aceleración hacia abajo esta masa de 3
kilogramos tendrá una aceleración hacia
arriba y de la misma proporción de otra
manera esta cuerda se rompería o se
estiraría y nosotros suponemos que esto
no está pasando aquí y esta suposición
de que esta cuerda no se estira ni se
rompe es la condición que nos permite
decir que la aceleración de este sistema
como si tuviéramos una sola masa total
con estas fuerzas externas en esta bueno
las fuerzas externas son aquellas
fuerzas que se ejercen en los objetos de
nuestro sistema por elementos que están
fuera del sistema
una de estas fuerzas externas es la
fuerza de gravedad ejercida en esta masa
de 5 kilogramos
esta fuerza de gravedad fg va a ser
igual a los 5 kilogramos de masa por 9.8
metros por segundo al cuadrado y así
encontramos la fuerza de gravedad y esto
será positivo o negativo
bueno la fuerza de gravedad va a jalar
este peso hacia abajo
si yo soltara este sistema este objeto
sería acelerado hacia abajo su
aceleración sería en esta dirección
echaría a andar mi sistema por lo que
aquí le pongo un signo positivo esta
masa de 5 kilogramos es la que va a
acelerar a todo el sistema por eso es
que usamos el signo positivo aquí y me
pregunto hay otras fuerzas que ponen en
movimiento a este sistema pues no sería
la única aunque yo me puedo preguntar
qué pasa con la atención que se
encuentra aquí en esta masa de tres
kilogramos esta tensión va a ser que se
ponga en movimiento mi sistema pues no
esto es una fuerza interna que se ejerce
entre los objetos de nuestro sistema y
las fuerzas internas siempre tendrán una
fuerza opuesta a ellas interna también
esta tensión va a oponerse al movimiento
de la base de los tres kilogramos pero
se va a equilibrar con esta tensión de
la masa de cinco kilogramos que trata de
evitar que ésta se mueva y si pensamos
en estas masas de tres y cinco
kilogramos como un solo objeto todas
estas fuerzas internas
van a cancelar ya que todo esto lo
estamos viendo como un gran sistema con
una masa de 5 kilogramos así que estas
fuerzas internas no las incluimos aquí
solo las fuerzas externas
otras fuerzas externas están tratando de
hacer que este sistema se mueva o no se
mueva bueno tenemos otra fuerza que está
tratando de evitar que se mueva este
sistema y esta es la fuerza de gravedad
que está siendo ejercida en esta masa de
3 kilogramos
esta fuerza está tratando de evitar que
se mueva el sistema qué tan grande es
esta fuerza pues será de 3 kilogramos
por 9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado y
esta fuerza va a tratar de evitar que se
mueva el sistema este sistema está
siendo acelerado o está siendo puesto en
movimiento por la fuerza de gravedad en
esta masa de 5 kilogramos que va hacia
abajo y esta fuerza de gravedad en esta
masa de 3 kilogramos está en sentido
opuesto al movimiento del sistema así
que será negativa porque se opone al
movimiento del sistema y esto a veces
confunde a las personas ya que dicen
bueno es que ambas masas tienen su
fuerza de gravedad con dirección hacia
abajo es la misma dirección pero aquí
hay que ver hacia dónde se está moviendo
todo el sistema y qué cosas se oponen a
ese movimiento estas dos fuerzas
deberían tener el mismo signo ya que
están apuntando a la misma dirección y
eso sería así si usáramos la segunda ley
de newton de la manera tradicional
pero no con este truco de contemplar
estas masas como una masa total única y
en donde nos interesa aquellas fuerzas
que están en la dirección del movimiento
o las que están en la dirección opuesta
las fuerzas que van en la misma
dirección que el movimiento del sistema
vamos a considerar las positivas y
aquellas fuerzas que se oponen al
movimiento del sistema vamos a
considerar las negativas las fuerzas que
van con el movimiento del sistema serán
fuerzas positivas y aquellas que se
resisten al movimiento del sistema serán
negativas y como esta fuerza se está
resistiendo al movimiento del sistema
por eso la consideramos negativa
en este sistema se está moviendo hacia
acá incluso esta masa de 3 kilogramos la
masa de tres kilogramos va hacia acá la
cuerda también se está moviendo hacia
acá y por supuesto esta masa de 5
kilogramos se está moviendo en esta
dirección es así como nos damos cuenta
de que todo el movimiento del sistema va
en esta dirección aunque la fuerza
actuando en esta masa de tres kilogramos
va en la dirección opuesta por eso es
que la consideramos negativa está
tratando de evitar que se acelere el
sistema como lo haría si no existiera
esta fuerza por eso es que los restamos
y ahora vamos a dividir todo esto entre
la masa total la masa total es de 53 es
decir 8 kilogramos hago los cálculos y
obtengo la aceleración del sistema
es de 2.45 metros por segundo al
cuadrado y esta es una forma rápida de
encontrar cuál es la aceleración total
de mi sistema pero hay que tener cuidado
si la pregunta fuera cuál es la
aceleración en la masa de 5 kilogramos
técnicamente esa aceleración sería igual
a menos 2.45 metros por segundo al
cuadrado pero como aquí nos están
pidiendo la magnitud de la aceleración
del sistema pero como aquí esta
aceleración va hacia abajo y por
convención la dirección hacia abajo
siempre va a ser negativa pues esta
aceleración tiene el signo menos y esta
magnitud por lo que no deben olvidar
estos signos si esto es lo que les
preguntan la aceleración en la masa de
tres kilogramos aquí esta aceleración
sería de más 2.45 metros por segundo al
cuadrado positiva porque la dirección va
hacia
cuando tenemos una dirección hacia
arriba va a tener el signo positivo así
que aquí hay que tener cuidado de si nos
preguntan la aceleración en un objeto en
particular poner el signo que le
corresponde dependiendo del sentido de
su aceleración y si nos piden encontrar
la atención pues ahorita sería mucho más
sencillo puedo encontrar esta atención
si me pidieran encontrar cuál es la
atención de la cuerda que conecta ambas
masas pues uso la segunda ley de newton
pero de la forma tradicional éste fue
sólo un truco para encontrar la magnitud
de la aceleración del sistema y ahora
que ya tenemos esta magnitud ya no vamos
a estar usando este truco
ahora voy a analizar esta masa de 5
kilogramos por sí sola y ahora voy a
decir que la aceleración de mi masa de 5
kilogramos aplicando la segunda ley de
newton va a ser igual a la fuerza neta
en esta masa de 5 kilogramos entre la
masa de 5 kilogramos conozco la
aceleración de esta masa de 5 kilogramos
pero si ahora vamos a tomar como
positivo lo que vaya hacia arriba tengo
que usarla aquí con el signo negativo va
a ser menos 2.45 metros por segundo al
cuadrado esto va a ser igual a la fuerza
neta en esta masa de 5 kilogramos aquí
voy a tener la atención hacia arriba y
bueno ustedes me pueden decir que acaso
la atención no era una fuerza interna y
no teníamos que tomarlo en cuenta
en efecto era una fuerza interna aquí y
por eso es que no la incluimos aquí pero
ahora estamos trabajando de la forma
tradicional así que ahora sí debemos
incluir las fuerzas que se ejercen en
nuestra masa de 5 kilogramos
estamos aplicando la segunda ley de
newton en la dirección vertical todo
esto es vertical
si son hacia arriba van a ser positivas
y si son hacia abajo van a ser negativas
como esta fuerza de gravedad que es de 5
kilogramos por 9.8 metros por segundo al
cuadrado
y esto lo divido entre mi masa de 5
kilogramos ya que es el objeto que
estamos analizando y no todo el sistema
como lo hicimos aquí ahora puedo
despejar mi tensión una forma
alternativa de hacer esto es considerar
todo lo que va hacia abajo como positivo
de manera que esta aceleración sería
positiva esta fuerza de gravedad sería
positiva y mi intención sería negativa
aunque yo aquí lo que voy a encontrar es
la magnitud de la atención ya que de
ambas maneras la cantidad es la misma
solo cambia el signo si pongo todo esto
en la calculadora voy a obtener que la
magnitud de mi tensión va a ser igual a
36.75 newtons que es menor que la fuerza
de gravedad lo cual tiene sentido ya que
si la tensión fuera mayor que la fuerza
de gravedad este objeto de 5 kilogramos
se movería hacia arriba en lugar de
hacia abajo y sabemos que esto no sucede
esta tensión tiene que ser menor a la
fuerza de gravedad para qué
objeto pueda acelerarse hacia abajo esta
es una forma rápida de encontrar la
magnitud de la aceleración de todo el
sistema al tratarlo como solo un objeto
y podemos considerarlo como un solo
objeto ya que todo esto se mueve con la
misma aceleración o tiene la misma
magnitud de aceleración si a esto lo
tratamos como un solo objeto entonces
solo nos van a interesar las fuerzas
externas y las fuerzas externas que
hacen que se mueva el sistema las
consideraremos positivas y aquellas
fuerzas externas que se resisten al
movimiento del sistema las
consideraremos negativas las vamos a
restar ya que tratan de evitar que se
mueva el sistema y todo esto lo vamos a
dividir entre la masa total de este
sistema
si esto le sigue pareciendo alguna clase
de magia matemática los invito a que
vean el video en donde resolvimos uno de
estos sistemas de la manera fácil y de
la manera difícil y verán que terminamos
con aquellas fuerzas externas que hacen
que se mueva el sistema y aquellas
fuerzas externas que evitan o que se
oponen a este movimiento del sistema
dividido entre la masa total del sistema
y eso nos dará la aceleración total del
sistema en esencia de lo que estamos
diciendo es que estas fuerzas internas
se van a cancelar si es que nosotros
conceptualizamos el sistema como un
objeto único ya que éstas ocurrirían
internamente y son opuestas entre sí una
trata de hacer que el sistema se mueva y
otra se opone a ello